but as you've just said chair the
purpose of this inquiry is not to reopen
so-called party gate it is to discover
whether or not I lied to Parliament
wittingly misled colleagues and the
country about what I knew and believed
about those Gatherings when I said that
the rules and the guidance had been
followed at number 10.
I'm here to
say to you hand on heart that I did not
lie to the house when those statements
were made they were made in good faith
and on the basis of what I honestly knew
and believed at the time
when this inquiry was set up I was
completely confident that you would find
nothing to show I knew or believed
anything else as indeed you have not I
was confident not because there's been
some kind of cover-up I was confident
because I knew that is what I believed
and that is why I said it
to understand why I believed it you have
to go back to a time before the Sue gray
report before the police investigation
back to a time where as the evidence
before the committee shows there was a
near Universal belief at number 10 that
the rules and guidance were being
complied with that is the general belief
that has been uncovered by your evidence
and it was that belief that governed
what I said in the house
and as soon as it was clear that I was
wrong and as soon as the Sue gray
investigation and the metropolitan
police investigation had concluded I
came to the House of Commons and I
corrected the record as I promised I
would I clearly could not have
anticipated the outcome by coming
earlier because I genuinely did not know
what the outcome would be and was deeply
shocked when fines were issued not least
since I had been told on a couple of
occasions at least by Sue gray that she
did not think the threshold of
criminality had been reached
I believe that the committee's work
helps to explain why I was so shocked
you've been investigating this for more
than 10 months and I thank you for what
you have done you've had access to a
vast body of evidence you have collected
and reviewed hundreds of pages of
transcripts of Sue Gray's interviews and
you have analyzed many thousands of
contemporary emails and WhatsApp
messages and other material
you found nothing
to show that I was warned in advance
that events in number 10 were illegal in
fact nothing to show that anyone raised
anxieties with me about any event
whether before or after it had taken
place
if there had been such anxiety about a
rule-breaking event at number 10 it were
unquestionably have been escalated to me
we all knew how vital it was to maintain
public confidence in the fight against
kovid that we should do what we were
asking the public to do
there's only one exception of course and
that's the testimony of Dominic Cummings
which is unsupported by any documentary
evidence and which plainly cannot be
relied upon he has every motive to lie
not only has the committee found nothing
incriminating it has gathered a huge
amount of evidence which demonstrates
very clearly that those working in
number 10 shared my belief that the
rules and the guidance were being
followed and that I received assurances
that there was no rule breaking a number
10.
the best and fairies course now would be
for the committee to publish all the
evidence it is assembled so that
Parliament and public can judge for
themselves
despite my repeated requests the
committee has refused to do this
as investigator prosecutor judge and
jury it has elected only to publish the
evidence which it considers
incriminating and not the evidence which
I rely on and which answers the charges
and despite assurances that we would be
permitted to add material that we rely
on into the core bundle published today
late last night we were told that the
committee was not willing to publish a
large number of extracts which I rely
upon in my defense that is manifestly
unfair
instead and in the absence of any
evidence that I deliberately misled
Parliament the committee is trying to
mount an argument that I must have known
that the guidance was not being followed
and that I Buried buried in my head as
we were fighting kovid was an
unarticulated belief that even if we
were following the rules We Were Somehow
failing to follow the guidance and you
have in your fourth report suggested
that it must have been obvious to me
because you have the photographs so let
me deal with this point head on because
it is nonsense these photos have now
been churned through the media for more
than a year and it seems to be the view
of the committee and sadly many members
of the public that they show me
attending rule-breaking parties where no
one was social distancing they show
nothing of the kind they show me giving
a few words of thanks at a work event
for a departing colleague they show me
with my red box passing on the way to
another meet teaching or heading back
into my flat to carry on working often
late Into the Night they show a few
people standing together as permitted by
the guidance where full social
distancing is not possible and where
mitigating measures are taken
they show events which I was never fined
for attending
I know the public will have had the
impression that these were covert photos
with their Sinister pixelations that
have been obtained by the media
the vast majority were in fact taken by
the official number 10 photographer
to say that we would have held illicit
events in number 10 while allowing these
events to be immortalized by an official
photographer is staggeringly implausible
there are a couple of photos where the
event is captured on Zoom as well as by
the official photographer which only
reinforces the point if we had an event
with it we believed was illicit or
unauthorized why would we have it on
Zoom when you never quite know who is on
the other side
most important of all if it was obvious
to me that these events were contrary to
the guidance and the rules then it must
have been equally obvious to dozens of
others including the most senior
officials in the country all of them
like me responsible for drawing up the
rules and it must have been obvious to
others in the building including the
current prime minister